wait what's this the hundred most
handsome faces of 2017 last year I was
18 I wonder if I'm on the list
wow so many handsome faces hide yourself
oh my god most handsome man ever 18 I
mean seven top ten I'm the top ten most
handsome man thank you wow what an honor
top ten Jesus Christ roll the intro
I don't think anything but can your
chair do this I bet you I bet you it can
oh it doesn't need to do that because it
can do it can do all you want and more I
don't need to I don't need to do that
you guys think you're so clever with
your chair memes huh you're not clever
you're on oh my god but can you do this
yeah I just what the hell is that setup
even is that yeah nothing like a little
reading some men's magazines on the side
but does it cost 399 I don't think so
this your chair cuts three ninety-nine I
don't think so so don't you even came to
me about to be who your chair doesn't do
this
Felix it's my fashion icon high-waisted
pants are stretchy look you know what I
look damn good in those high-waisted
pants and I'll tell you why because I'm
top 10 back on top 10 it's this 3d its
3d lost great yeah oh my god a stupid
meme I wish I never brought it up hi
Marcia will you marry me no you're ugly
it may have a boyfriend
wait but can you do this David Howell
when is this gonna get old yet I don't
know top pain the pain the last game you
died in is how you'll die in real life
how did you go guess I'll amber getting
over it hmm easy that game was easy
please can you recommend me some
actually challenging games my god
getting over eight that's good actually
I never thought of that
well done I released a chair recently
but everyone thought he was too
expensive I was pretty bummed out about
it but I can do this so whatever
why has this channel at this point been
completely able
all around the [ __ ] learn how to pet
your dog or oh my god someone actually
did that well good job I don't know what
to tell you my god who wore it better is
that it seriously a question huh can we
just take a moment to appreciate top ten
top ten everybody did miley cyrus get
top ten
I don't think so dudes the dumbass when
you finally beat a game without dying
once but forget to say Sarah with this
yep I did
I mean I may be a dumbass but I'm
talking young great you found my old
class book congratulations
what do you want man I think I was
overdue a haircut he was so cute
where did we go wrong yo Steve nice
chair thank you pooch book pay me duty
if you start watching PewDiePie video at
exactly 11:00 49:59 on New Year's Eve
Peter pious video will get finished at
the stroke of midnight good job good
good job good meme hey what is this this
took the mean to another level soul and
please don't arrest me
bag charm 115 dollars and people are
complaining about this incredible chair
this incredible life-changing chair but
literally can you do this when the guy
behind you on the plane asked you to not
lean back but can you do this sad but
true
looking at means looking at memes
looking at memes no no no no you laugh
you lose is reacting to memes meme
review is explaining the Meuse memes
digging deeper under me look wow its
examining the means yes of course
original content as always thank you
Johnny English has a chair oh my god
more more more chair memes everybody
wait no no not Johnny English no wait no
wait no Johnny no Johnny Johnny
that's why that's why you need to put
down 399 only 399 by the way dudes
finishing a game giving a brofist and is
on trending what the f is this 2013
that's right
Christian channel now things are
different things are better
damn it why I you know what don't answer
that
don't answer that PewDiePie making force
trendy content from use free to pie
making whatever he wants
name review thank you Thank You Maria
and then you know thank you for
understand
PewDiePie the Beast nice one oh my god a
new challenger approaches I will fight
him I will fight this wing if my life
depended on it but can he do this huh no
now we can wish to fame I have really
strong mental sank oh ok show me you
beating the game then huh show me your
original content viking beard 399
chairman review status with good open
Christian came you to bring one god damn
it
0 deaths in every games brofist in every
video your life you lose support from
truth pays off that is so cute Thank You
Mirage for if 27 a new viewer may think
that this is a picture of an empty room
that we know
we now worry is hey getting over it fan
your fan art Sam Jones thank you very
much
very dope very I mean a very nice oh no
it's still not ten minutes burners meme
consider yourself lucky
remember fix it Felix this is him now
they'll all get upgrade from a hammer to
a sledge hammer hail ye top ten
everybody can we get this video top 10
trending that was all the memes I pull
good job I'm a special thanks to my
sponsor my family my friends my job my
enemy okay remember to like and always
squat feminine jujitsu